Warum bringt man eine Mannschaft, die so funktioniert hat in dieser Situation, dass man sagt, man muss sie auf den Gegner anpassen? 2008 angepasst. Gegen Spanien im Finale verloren, gewachsenes Gebild der Spanier, man wusste wie die spielen. Die haben uns angepasst, sind raus. 2010, Südafrika, angepasst an die Spanier, rausgeflogen. 2012, angepasst an die Italiener, rausgeflogen. Achtung, und jetzt kommt der Clou. 2014, ab dem Viertelfinale, hat Jogi Löw jede Idee seiner Trainer, seines Stabs ignoriert und hat der Mannschaft vertraut. Und sie haben dreimal mit der gleichen Mannschaft ab Viertelfinale gespielt. So gewinnt man Titel.
Ja, so gewinnt man Titel. Ich begrüße euch zum Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Mein Name ist Max Jacob Ost und was wir gerade hier im Intro gehört haben, das war vielleicht der Aufreger in Sachen Taktik bei dieser Europameisterschaft. Mehmet Scholl eschofiert sich über die Dreierkette, die gegen Italien eingesetzt wurde im Viertelfinale. Er hat da auch eine persönliche Note reingebracht. Die habe ich aber rausgeschnitten, weil er sich später dafür entschuldigt hat. Das wollen wir ihm nicht weiter vorhalten. Aber ihr bekommt schon einen Eindruck, um was es in diesem Tribünengespräch gehen soll, nämlich um Taktik und Spielanalyse. Und ich könnte mir keinen besseren Gesprächspartner vorstellen als derjenige, der mir jetzt live gegenüber sitzt. Und zwar Dr. Alexander Schmalhofer, Leiter des Fachbereichs Taktik und Spielanalyse am Institut für Fußballmanagement. Servus Herr Doktor. Schön, dass du mit dabei bist. Ich glaube, wir können bei Alex bleiben. Wir stellen dich gleich noch näher vor. Bevor wir ins Thema reingehen, muss ich aber noch drei Hörern danken, nämlich Nicola Elischa Matmou, Christian Bien und den über Twitter sehr gut bekannten Ralf Heuer. Vielen Dank. Ihr drei habt uns unterstützt. Unser rasenfunk.de unterstützen. Von euch kommt übrigens auch alle Hardware, mit der heute aufgenommen wird, exklusive meines Laptops. Alles von den Hörern. Vielen Dank dafür. Alex nickt, alle kennen ihn. Ja, wir haben tolle Hörer. Vielen Dank dafür. Und wer uns unterstützen möchte, kann das unter rasenfunk.de unterstützen tun. Und in diesem Sinne würde ich sagen, starten wir in ein Tribünengespräch, von dem wir, glaube ich, beide gespannt sind, über was wir heute alles sprechen werden. Spiel- und Taktikanalyse – für mich so ein bisschen eine Blackbox. Ich gucke da so leihenhaft von außen rein, versuche mir einen Reim drauf zu machen. Und du darfst mir heute erklären, was das eigentlich so bedeutet. Aber zunächst mal würde mich interessieren, wie bist du eigentlich zu dem Beruf gekommen? Das wird ja wahrscheinlich nicht von Anfang an ein Berufswunsch gewesen sein.
Also ich glaube, zunächst einmal ist es so, dass man insgesamt Spielanalyse auch nicht überbewerten sollte. Ich glaube, es gibt so einen Spruch, den ich ganz cool finde und habe ich beim DFB mal gelernt. Es gibt auch Trainer, die können den Erfolg der Mannschaft nicht verhindern. Okay, das ist ein guter Spruch. Ich weiß, ich schieße mir jetzt ins eigene Knie, aber wir wissen nicht, welchen Anteil hat die Spielanalyse, egal wie umfassend sie betrieben wird, und auch eine Spielphilosophie auf den Erfolg. Das will ich einfach mal im Grunde hier reinschmeißen, weil der Hype schon so durchaus stark ist in der letzten Zeit, dass Spielanalyse nicht über Sieg oder Niederlage entscheidet. Man hat aber die Möglichkeit, die Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit zu erhöhen. Das ist jetzt nichts wissenschaftlich Nachgewiesenes, aber das ist eine These von meiner Seite, basierend auf den Erfahrungen, die ich gemacht habe. In der Reduktion des Ganzen ist es elementar, dass man Kernaussagen hinkriegt, die für den Trainer ins Training eingebaut werden können, die bei der Mannschaft ankommen und die einfach wirklich einen klaren Matchplan darstellen, dass jeder weiß, was er zu tun hat. Auch da ist es dann, glaube ich, sehr mannschaftsabhängig, wie viel Information ich jedem Einzelnen gebe. Dann bin ich wieder auch beim Chef-Trainer, der, glaube ich, eine elementare Rolle spielt, der auch vielleicht so ein Stück weit entscheiden muss, wie viel baue ich jetzt auch in die Mannschaftsanalyse ein, wie viel Info gebe ich auch so einem Spieler im Eins-zu-eins-Gespräch oder in der Gruppenanalyse zum Beispiel. Ein Patentrezept, glaube ich, gibt es nicht, aber Fakt ist, man muss es in jedem Fall auch reduzieren. Und das ist vielleicht, wenn ich das noch anführen darf, das ist auch die Schwierigkeit, finde ich. Also da kann ich jetzt auch nur so aus meiner persönlichen Erfahrung sprechen. Das ist auch die Schwierigkeit, wenn man mit so einem Spiel anfängt. Also jetzt gehen wir mal davon aus, dass das eine Mannschaft ist, die man nicht kennt. Wenn wir jetzt Bundesligamannschaft anschauen, dann haben wir schon ungefähr eine Idee im Kopf, wie die spielen. Wir kennen die Spieler so ein bisschen. Jetzt spielt er aber dann zum Beispiel Dortmund in zwei Wochen in Warschau. Die Dortmunder kennen natürlich Warschau ganz bestimmt, haben sie schon oft gesehen. Aber wir gehen jetzt mal von dem Fall aus, wir kennen die Mannschaft nicht. Dann fangen die an, sich mit einem gewissen Spielzug vorzukombinieren. Wir denken, das muss ein Muster sein, aber wir sehen das Ganze nicht nochmal. War das jetzt ein Einzelfall oder wird es noch zum Muster?
Da muss man dann mehr Spiele sehen.
Richtig, da muss man dann wiederum mehr Spiele sehen. Da sind wir wieder bei vorher. Dieser Durchschnitt ist schwierig. Die Bundesliga untereinander kennt sich natürlich auch sehr gut. Die wissen ungefähr auch, wie der Gegner agiert und schaut sich dann nochmal Dinge an. Und dann kommen die auf ein gutes Ergebnis. Mannschaften, die unbekannt sind, sind da einfach deutlich schwieriger.
Für die Schlusskonferenz, in der ich über den Bundesligaspieltag spreche mit meinen Gästen, schaue ich mir ja auch die fünf Livespiele, die man angucken kann als normaler Fan, der sich nichts aufnimmt, die sehe ich immer über die volle Länge normalerweise. Und bei allen anderen gucke ich dann manchmal nehme ich mir auch noch was auf und schaue mir das dann auch noch nachts an, je nach Zeitmanagement auch. Und es kommt immer wieder vor, dass ich Spiele sehe und aber einigermaßen erkenntnislos da rausgehe. Und dann weiß ich manchmal nicht, liegt das jetzt an meiner Tagesform? Man hat auch manchmal auch einfach einen schlechten Tag oder man wusste halt schon, dass das ein 0-0 ist und ist dann vielleicht schon mit irgendwie dover Laune da reingegangen. Ist das bei dir auch manchmal so, dass du sagst, gut, schön, dass ich mir jetzt dieses Spiel hier in kondensierter Art und Weise noch mal reingezogen habe, aber eigentlich habe ich daraus nicht gelernt?
Ja, zu 100 Prozent. Okay, das tröstet mich. Ich kann da jetzt auch wiederum nur für mich sprechen, ich weiß nicht, wie es den Kollegen geht. Das kommt schon mal vor, dass dann einfach keine großen Erkenntnisse zu sehen sind. Und man halt dann wirklich aber trotzdem diese reduzierten Erkenntnisse irgendwo mitnimmt. Und selbst die geben einem eine Information. Und was man natürlich auch immer ganz gut machen kann, vielleicht auch ein Tipp irgendwie, wenn ich jetzt eine Mannschaft analysiere und ich finde einfach nicht dieses Muster, ich finde nicht das, was sie ausmacht oder so, dann kann man schon versuchen, auch sehr stark über die Einzelspieler zu kommen. Also welche Rollen haben auch die Einzelspieler in diesem System? Also was ist auffällig, wie sie sich mit dem Ball oder gegen den Ball bewegen, wo vielleicht dadurch auch Räume entstehen oder ähnliches. Und das ist eine Ebene, die man da immer ganz gut auch anschauen kann, um vielleicht auch noch Erkenntnisse, die interessant sind, mitzunehmen.
Welche Rolle spielen da für dich Statistiken?
Ja, ich muss sagen, ich stehe Statistiken insgesamt schon relativ kritisch gegenüber. Auch wenn ich mich zuletzt sehr intensiv damit auseinandergesetzt habe. Ich glaube, dass wir uns auch da aktuell in einer Wandlung befinden. Ich glaube, dass wir eine lange Zeit – es ist noch gar nicht so lange her – da kamen dann unglaublich viele Statistiken und dann war es erstmal so, wow, Buff, was können wir jetzt alles über diesen Fußball wissen? Und irgendwie alle haben damit gearbeitet und viel läuft auch medial ab, was Statistiken betrifft, weil da kann man immer natürlich schöne Fakten hinklatschen und auch mal eine Schlagzeile bilden.
Es wirkt auch immer wahnsinnig gebildet. Also allein, wenn du die Torschüsse zitiert hast eines Spiels, dann habe ich immer den Eindruck, dass das manche auch so ein bisschen als das Abzeichen verwenden, um zu sagen, hier guck mal, wie ich mich mit diesem Spiel beschäftigt habe.
Ja, klar, kommt auch noch mit dazu. Aber es ist halt, und da bin ich bei meinem Anfangspunkt von der Doktorarbeit eigentlich, es hat zunächst nichts oder nur wenig oft was direkt mit dem Trainingsplatz zu tun. Also das, was ich als Mehrwert gewinnen kann aus den Daten. Ich habe ein doofes Beispiel auch, das erzähle ich gerne immer wieder, weil ich es aber auch so sauwitzig finde, ist, es spielte Team A gegen Team B und Team A bezwang Team B mit 5 zu 0. Und dann wurde der Experte Y, vielleicht war es auch der Trainer, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr, zumindest würde ich es auch nicht verraten, wurde dann nach dem Spiel gefragt, warum ist denn dieses Spiel jetzt 5 zu 0 ausgegangen. Und dann Blick auf die Daten und dann hieß es, naja, ist doch klar, die sind im Schnitt halt auch 6 Kilometer mehr gelaufen oder 4 oder was weiß ich. Und dann hat man sich aber die Daten ein bisschen genauer angeschaut und Ende vom Lied war, dass die Tore oder dass die nach den Toren eigentlich immer zum Jubeln zu den Fans gelaufen sind, die halt in dem Fall auf der anderen Seite vom Stadion waren, da natürlich relativ viel gelaufene Meter entstanden sind. Und das ist halt so ein Kernbeispiel davon, wie man halt Daten natürlich nicht einsetzen darf, indem man sie einfach fehl interpretieren kann. Und das ist so die Gefahr des Ganzen.
Aber dann kann ich mich ja nie auf Daten verlassen, weil ich habe ja auch nicht die Zeit, das Spiel so oft und mit so vielen Augen quasi anzugucken, dass ich mir immer sicher sein kann, dass da jetzt kein Fehler oder keine Missinterpretation drin liegt. Die Daten sind ja nicht falsch. Muss ich mich nicht ab einem gewissen Punkt auch manchmal auf Daten verlassen können?
Absolut. Und das kann man heutzutage auch. Also die Daten werden ja sehr gut erhoben auch und die Daten entwickeln sich ja weiter. Ich will bloß damit sagen, man muss einfach vorsichtig sein, wie man die Daten interpretiert und einsetzt. Und in dem Fall konnte man sie halt einfach nicht als schlüssiges Argument verwenden. Und die Entwicklung zeigt eben, dass dann viele fanden es dann immer super und klasse, mit diesen Daten zu arbeiten. Und irgendwann hatte man aber so viel Daten, dass man irgendwann mal sich überlegt hat, hey, okay, und was kann ich jetzt eigentlich damit anfangen? In der Fußballforschung sozusagen war es dann oft so, dass man versucht hat, Zusammenhänge zu suchen. Also ich schmeiße in irgendeine Maschine alle Daten rein und dann schaue ich mal, was hinten rauskommt. Zum Beispiel. Und dann kommt von mir aus raus, naja, ich gewinne mehr Spiele, wenn ich mehr Flanken schlage. Jetzt bin ich aber als Spielanalyst im Verein und dann gehe ich zu meinem Trainer und sage, hey, wir gewinnen mehr Spiele, wenn wir mehr Flanken schlagen. Dann sagt er zu mir, hol dir deinen Vertrag ab. Die Information kann ich nicht gebrauchen, sozusagen.
Aber das ist doch dieser Ansatz, den zum Beispiel so ein Club wie North Joland in Dänemark, glaube ich, ist es verfolgt und was ja so ein bisschen aus dem Baseball rüber kam. Ich habe gerade – Moneyball heißt glaube ich der Film mit Brad Pitt – mit dem – ach Gott, jetzt habe ich gerade den Teamnamen vergessen – auf jeden Fall ein Baseball-Team, das sehr nach Statistiken dann gescoutet hat und so dann sportlichen Erfolg hatte. Und das ist inzwischen ja auch bei manchen Teams im Fußball gelandet, wobei man schon mal die Einschränkung machen muss, Baseball ist ein noch viel krass datenbasierterer Sport als Fußball. Aber dennoch gibt es ja diese Ansätze.
Ja, absolut. Und ich will diese Ansätze auch gar nicht schlechtreden. Das ist nur nicht mein persönlicher Ansatz. Und für mich sind diese Vereine dann wie Mütiland, glaube ich, heißt auch einer, so ein bisschen eine Blackbox. Weil man kriegt sie aktuell auch nur so ein Stück weit von außen mit. Wie viel dann irgendwie mit den Statistiken gemacht wird, was genau gemacht wird, ist ja noch so ein bisschen Blackbox, würde ich jetzt behaupten.
Ich habe zum Beispiel ein Beispiel gelesen, wo die Flanke gegenüber dem vertikalen Pass in den Strafraum gestellt wurde. Das ist ein bisschen schief, weil nicht immer, wenn du in der Flankenposition bist, bist du auch in der Position, vertikalen Pass zu spielen. Aber immerhin könntest du einen Pass in den Strafraum spielen. Wo eben rauskam, allein vom Statistischen her gesehen, ist es immer schlau, auf die Flanke zu verzichten und versuchen, den vertikalen Pass zu spielen. Weil der in einem von zehn Fällen zum Tor führt und die Flanke eben in weniger Fällen. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, naja, das ist schon eine Erkenntnis. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt eine Mannschaft habe, wo vorne ein 2, 50 Meter Stürmer drin steht, der nicht dribbeln kann, dann hilft mir diese Erkenntnis nicht weiter, ich werde bei Flanken bleiben. Aber das ist doch schon etwas, wo man sagen kann, das ist durchaus eine interessante Erkenntnis. Weil vielleicht legt das ja auch größere Muster global gesehen im Fußball auf. Dadurch, dass Mannschaften relativ ähnlich verteidigen. Das Zentrum ist jetzt bei allen Mannschaften dicht. Das hat man auch bei der Europameisterschaft super gesehen. Alle Mannschaften können das inzwischen. Manche können es, indem sie da drei Defensive hinstellen. Manche schaffen es aber auch sogar nur mit einem Defensiven. Aber das Zentrum, der Bereich 20 Meter vorm Tor zentral, der ist relativ dicht. Und deswegen passiert viel über die Flügel. Und sowas könnten doch auch solche Big-Data-Analysen da so einem Hinweise drauf geben, was quasi die Mittel sind, auf die Mannschaften weniger gut vorbereitet sind vielleicht.
Ja, ein langgezogenes Ja. Ich glaube, du hast ja jetzt schon Beispiele genannt, die ja eigentlich schon sehr stark in die fußballspezifischere Richtung gehen. Also die schon auch eingesetzt werden, um Fragen zu beantworten, die die Praxis interessieren. Das ist ja schon mal der richtige Ansatz, finde ich. Das hatten wir eine lange Zeit nicht, und jetzt haben wir es aber. Oder jetzt bewegen wir uns Schritt für Schritt dahin. Jetzt habe ich so quasi meinen historischen Abschnitt von vorher damit beendet. Ich glaube, aber trotzdem, und du hast das Beispiel ja auch selber genannt, dass du es nicht verallgemeinern kannst. Also diese verallgemeinerte Aussage, 9 von 10 oder von mir aus 99 von 100 oder wie auch immer, ist halt unglaublich schwierig jetzt auch für mich verwertbar als Trainer einer Mannschaft. Wenn du es mir jetzt vielleicht bezogen auf meine Mannschaft sagst, und bei uns war das so und so oft, in so und so vielen Fällen war das dann so und so, dann hat es denke ich eine größere Bedeutung auch. Aber dann beziehst du schon auf deine eigene Mannschaft. Und dann bist du so in dem Konstrukt auch oder in so einem Feld, dass der Analyst in einem Verein auch bearbeiten kann, sollte, wie auch immer, dass er diese Daten, die er zur Verfügung hat, dass er die spezifisch auf die eigene Mannschaft auch wirklich einsetzt. Und das ist glaube ich so ein Weg, der richtig ist. Ich nenne dir aber mal ein anderes Beispiel, wenn wir jetzt wieder bei diesen Mustern sind. Im Grunde geht es darum, einen Matchplan zu erstellen. Und wenn jetzt eine Mannschaft läuft auf eine gewisse Art und Weise an, dann kann ich das Spiel auf eine gewisse Art und Weise eröffnen, um diese erste Verteidigungslinie beispielsweise zu überspielen. Jetzt kann ich da sagen, wir spielen immer über unseren linken Außenverteidiger, weil den ihr rechter äußerer Mittelfeldspieler zum Beispiel, der steht immer viel zu breit. Und dann können wir von da den Pass ins Zentrum spielen. Und dann bin ich einen Schritt weiter, was das Spiel betrifft. Die Frage ist, welche Daten geben mir diese Informationen?
Ja gut, dafür muss man es gesehen haben, das stimmt schon.
Das ist halt so die Gradwanderung, wie ich da Daten einsetze. Ich persönlich finde – und wir haben ein sehr großes Projekt für die Deutsche Fußballliga da auch umgesetzt – wir haben versucht, das Blatt umzudrehen und nicht die Daten als Grundlage zu nehmen und zu sehen, was kann ich aus den Daten ziehen, sondern wirklich erstmal die Frage zu stellen, was will ich in der Praxis, was will ich als Trainer zum Beispiel, denn eigentlich wissen? Und was ich wissen will, sind die Dinge, die wir jetzt schon mehrmals genannt haben. Diese Unterkategorien, wenn man so will, im Spiel mit dem Ball und im Spiel gegen den Spiel, Eröffnungen etc. Und was wir gemacht haben, ist diese Daten als Grundlage zu nehmen. Also wir haben die Möglichkeit gehabt, Positions- und Ereignisdaten, die es in der Bundesliga gibt. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Begrifflichkeiten…
Erklärst du mal kurz für die Hörer.
Gerne. Also Positionsdaten, wie der Name schon sagt, sind die Positionen der Spieler und des Balles. Das wird mehrmals pro Sekunde festgehalten, sodass ich immer eigentlich weiß, wo der Spieler ist. Und so entstehen dann z.B. auch sogenannte Heatmaps, die man ja so kennt. Und Event- oder Ereignisdaten sind dann eben Aktionen, Schüsse, Pässe, Tacklings usw. Und im Grunde wird natürlich versucht, rein aus diesen Positions- und Ereignisdaten Informationen rauszuziehen. Und wir haben gesagt, okay, wir wollen z.B. wissen, mit welchem Angriffsverhalten versucht denn eine Mannschaft Torschancen zu erspielen. Und haben gesagt, okay, was für Angriffsverhalten gibt es denn z.B.? Es gibt so das klassische Ballbesitzspiel, Beispiel FC Bayern, wo man aus den Positionen heraus viele Pässe, geringer Raumgewinn gegen eine geordnete Defensive. Dann gibt es die Möglichkeit, den Schnellangriff des Spiels in die Tiefe zu bevorzugen. Das heißt z.B. von hinten wirklich immer den langen Ball zu spielen, dann vielleicht auf den zweiten Ball zu gehen. Das heißt, du spielst wenige Pässe, erst aber einen sehr hohen Raumgewinn. Und dann gibt es auch das klassische Konterspiel, wo du sagst, du stehst halt tief und versuchst, den Ball zu erobern und dann ab die Post. Das sind so drei Verhaltensweisen, die vieles schon mal abbilden. Wir haben es beispielsweise in dem Projekt geschafft, dass wir mit diesen Daten dieses Angriffsverhalten in einem Spiel extrahieren können. Dass wir im Nachhinein sagen können, also, ihr habt so und so viele Positionsangriffe gespielt, so und so viele Konterangriffe gespielt und wir sind sogar prinzipiell in der Lage, die Videosequenzen dann auch auszuspucken, dass du dir als Analyst gar nicht mehr prinzipiell das ganze Spiel anschauen müsstest, sondern du könntest dir einfach alle Positionsangriffe anschauen und hättest dadurch auch natürlich die Spieleröffnung usw. usf. Und das finde ich einen Ansatz, der total spannend ist, auch im Einsatz der Daten.
Okay, das heißt quasi aus den Daten dann gleich was rausgezogen. Ich stehe ja immer – also ich schaue mir logischerweise auch in der Vorbereitung der Sendung immer alle Statistiken zu den Spielen an, aber zitiere auch nur die, die ich tatsächlich für relevant halte. Also wenn die Statistik entweder mich bestätigt neben dem, was ich gesehen habe, oder aber auch wenn die Statistik mich widerlegt war, dann könnte es auch sein, dass ich vielleicht etwas falsch beobachtet habe. Aber was ich grundsätzlich immer viel, viel wertvoller finde als die reinen Zahlen, ist alles, was auf dem Spielfeld dargestellt wird. Also die berühmten Pfeilgrafiken, in denen ich sehen kann, lange Bälle, welche davon erfolgreich waren, da kann man so oft Muster kennen. Oder ich mag auch einfach mir anzugucken, wie ist die Ballverteilung der Ballkontakte von einzelnen Spielern. Das ist im Grunde ein bisschen wie eine Heatmap, aber schon auch ein bisschen anders. Also bei Darmstadt sah es immer total lustig aus, weil die Außen immer die Seitenlinie noch mal quasi fetter gemalt haben, weil die halt einfach nur auf den Flügeln geschickt wurden im Eröffnungsspiel. Ich finde, dass es über den rein zahlen Aspekt hin helfen mir persönlich diese Daten mehr. Zumindest so von meinem persönlichen Gefühl her. Aber gleichzeitig würde ich sagen, dass es eine Art und Weise auf ein Fußballspiel zu gucken, auch retrospektiv, die schon sehr sophisticated ist und schon sehr akademisch auch. Die Medien haben doch eigentlich gar nicht die Chance, sowas einzusetzen, zumindest nicht in der direkten Nachberichterstattung. Da ist es doch eigentlich logisch, dass man bei so etwas wie Torschussverhältnis stehen bleibt. Oder würdest du dir was anderes wünschen?
Ja, das kommt jetzt im Grunde darauf an, wie viel Zeit habe ich zur Verfügung und wie knapp ist es nach dem Spiel. Wobei die Daten ja live reinlaufen. Also die Daten sind abrufbar. Ich glaube auch, um vielleicht für die Daten nochmal zu sprechen, ich schaue mir auch bei jedem Spiel, wenn ich Daten habe, schaue ich sie mir auch an. Also ich will es nicht komplett verwerfen. Ich finde, dass es in der Spielanalyse elementar ist, sie hinzuzufügen und sie zu haben auch und Infos herauszuziehen. Vor allem, wie du sagst, wenn man es dann mit Pfeilen in Verbindungen bringen kann, wo man dann eben wieder Muster rauslesen kann. Und das ist aber der Ansatz, den ich dann entscheiden finde. Ich glaube, was die Berichterstattung betrifft, würde ich mir sowieso wünschen, dass wir insgesamt noch ein bisschen detaillierter arbeiten. Also auch zum Beispiel Dinge mit einbeziehen oder vielleicht auch mal Fragen an Trainer stellen, die auch taktisch wirklich in der Tiefe sind. Also ich habe es zum Beispiel bei Pep Guardiola erlebt. Wenn man dem in Spanien eine Frage gestellt hat, die einen taktischen Hintergrund hatte, wo er wirklich gemerkt hat, wow, der hat sich damit jetzt intensiv auseinandergesetzt und der will von mir eine ernsthafte Aussage dazu haben, dann hat er leuchtende Augen gekriegt und hat diese Frage beantwortet. Und ich glaube, dass das etwas ist, was wir tatsächlich vielleicht noch so ein Stück weit optimieren können.
Ja, man hat den Eindruck bekommen, dass das einer der Gründe war, warum er nicht ganz so glücklich immer war, wenn er mit Medienvertretern sprechen musste. Das war, glaube ich, einer der Aspekte, dass er sich zu oft auf die Frage reduziert hat, warum haben sie die Champions League noch nicht gewonnen und zu wenig vielleicht um solche Dinge ging. Und jetzt hast du ja vorhin aber auch schon richtigerweise gesagt, Spielanalyse darf man auch nicht überbewerten. Wie analysiert man denn eigentlich den Faktor Zufall, der ja eigentlich vielleicht gerade weil so viele Mannschaften gelernt haben zu verteidigen, gerade eine größere Rolle spielt denn je? Ich bin mir da mal so gar nicht sicher.
Also in der Forschung wurde der Faktor Zufall immer wieder auch analysiert und so weiter und so fort. Möchte ich aber gar nicht darauf eingehen. Ich habe Frank Wormuth, den Leiter der Fußballlehrerausbildung auf einem Kongress mal gehört. Er meinte, im Fußball gibt es keinen Zufall.
Okay, interessant.
Das fand ich einen ganz interessanten Ansatz. Ich glaube, dass man…
Aber das ist doch ein bisschen zu krass, oder? Das kann ich doch nicht sagen. Also wenn jemand über den Ball haut, dann hat das doch… Das ist doch Zufall.
Ja, oder es ist ein technischer…
Er war falsch zum Beigesstand.
technischer Mangel, ja. Also, es ist ein Ansatz. Ich finde ihn nicht uninteressant. Ich glaube, dass man den Zufall erstmal so hinnehmen muss, wie er ist im Fußball. Und man kann ihn sicher teilweise auch zur Nutze machen. Also es gibt ja Herangehensweisen. Eine Zeit lang hat es Leverkusen auch echt perfektioniert, die immer wieder auf den zweiten Ball gespielt haben. Also da war dann Kiesling ganz vorne mit dabei und dann wurde halt auch ein langer Ball auf Kiesling geplant gespielt. Und Kiesling hatte dann mehrere Optionen. Er konnte den Ball halten, die anderen konnten nachrücken oder er konnte ihn ablegen. Dann war alles wunderbar, weil dann war ich in einer guten Position. Oder es war halt so, dass der Zweikampf nicht gewonnen wurde. Und dann wurde aber sehr stark versucht, über so ein provoziertes Gegenpressing den Ball direkt wieder zu erobern. Und in dieser Unordnung, sind wir wieder bei dem Thema, spielt Zufall eine riesen Rolle. Wie du sagst, dann springt halt der Ball vom rechten Bein ans linke, vom anderen und so und plötzlich bin ich aber in Ballbesitz. Ich habe aber diesen Zufall vorher provoziert. Und deswegen kann man das schon durchaus sich zu Nutze machen auf der einen Seite. Man kann aber auch versuchen, den Zufall bestmöglich zu minimieren, indem ich halt, so wie die Bayern zum Beispiel, eine mega Spielkontrolle habe.
Wobei sie auch sehr vom Zufall auch profitieren. Ich habe jetzt gestern tatsächlich nochmal das Spiel gegen Juve gesehen, das Rückspiel, mit dem 1 zu 2 und 2 zu 2 in 75. und 90 plus 2. Minute. Und beide Flanken, die zu den Toren geführt haben, einmal Lewandowski, einmal Müller, waren quasi nach einem Ballverlust, denen sie dann schnell den Ball zurück gewonnen. Und dann war Juve zweimal nicht richtig geordnet. Einmal war es so, dass sie nicht schnell genug rausgerückt haben, und Costa konnte dann eine wunderbare Flank geschlagen. Das war dann in dem Moment, wo er in der Luft war, nicht mehr zu verteidigen, der Ball. Und das andere Mal war es dann Pass nach außen und dann die Flanke an den zweiten Pfosten. Da ist dann noch ein zweiter Fehler passiert. Aber jetzt verliere ich mich in Details.
Aber jetzt stelle ich dir mal eine Frage. Was genau davon war jetzt der Zufall?
Der erste Ballverlust.
Das Gegner.
Nein, Bayern hat quasi im Offensivspiel den Ball verloren. Und dann haben sie ihn aber gleich wieder zurück gewonnen. Und ich würde sagen, der Ballverlust ist der Zufall. Das Zurückgewinnen kommt aus ihrer Ordnung heraus und aus dem Gegenpressing, was Pep eben beigebracht hat. Oder willst du mir jetzt sagen, sie haben absichtlich den Ball verloren? Das gibt es ja auch manchmal, dass man sagt, manche, es würden bewusst Fehlpässe gespielt. Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe das noch nie gesehen, dass ich das Gefühl hatte, oh, dieser Fehlpass, der war jetzt aber extra gespielt.
Ja, doch. Ich habe es schon mal gesehen. Zumindest habe ich es mir eingebildet. Aber ich meine, wenn wir über sowas diskutieren, dann sind wir fast schon auf einer spirituellen Ebene. Weil wer entscheidet denn, dass jetzt der Ball da verloren geht oder nicht? Ja, wie auch immer er heißt. Ob es der Fußballgott ist oder wer auch immer es ist. Ich meine, es gibt Dinge, die können wir nicht kontrollieren. Und ob wir es dann Zufall taufen oder wie auch immer, sei dahingestellt. Ich glaube, das Elementare in dem Fall ist halt nur, den Zufall sich in dem Fall wieder zunutze zu machen und dann halt direkt wieder in den Zweikampf zu kommen. Wieder ins Gegenpressing zu gehen und den Ball in einer guten Position wiederzuholen. Ich glaube, da kommen wir, was den Zufall betrifft, in eine Diskussion, die beim Fußball irgendwo anfängt und aufhört irgendwo bei grundsätzlichen Dingen, die uns im Sinn des Lebens beschäftigen.
Ja, ich verstehe deinen Ansatz und stimme den auch in Teilen zu. Ich habe es ja vorhin schon angesprochen, es gibt ja diese Spiele, die so vollkommen merkwürdig laufen, wo man ohne Erkenntnisgewinn rausgeht. Manchmal kann man auch gar nicht im Nachhinein sagen, warum hätte die Mannschaft gewonnen. Man ist so ein bisschen ratlos. Manchmal fehlt es nicht, dass man einfach zugesteht. Rein mit analytischen Aspekten ist das jetzt nicht zu erklären. Es gibt ja auch z.B. Taktik-Blocks, die sehr genau jedes Spiel sezieren. Da denke ich mir manchmal, sorry Jungs, aber zu dem Match hättet ihr jetzt eigentlich schreiben müssen. Die Sachen sind uns aufgefallen, aber so ganz hat es nicht ganz mit dem zu tun gehabt, was rausgekommen ist. Es gibt ja noch die Faktoren Tagesform, Stand der Sonne, Gegenwind, von der Freundin getrennt.
Was hab ich gegessen? Wie hab ich geschlafen?
Genau.
Absolut. Das ist das, was ich eingangs meinte, wo ich gesagt habe, man muss vorsichtig sein, dass man die Spielanalyse nicht auf irgendeinen Sockel stellt, auf der sie tatsächlich eben nicht ist. Ich glaube, man muss unterscheiden. Zum einen ist es so, und da bin ich beim Thema Muster, dass man diese Muster findet und so und klar und dann stellen wir uns auf die Mannschaft ein und dann versuchen wir, denen ihre Stärken zu schwächen und denen ihre Schwächen zu unseren Stärken zu machen. So, einfach gesprochen. Wie es dann zu Toren und Torschancen kommt, steht nochmal auf einem völlig anderen Blatt. Da geb ich dir zu 100 Prozent Recht und da gibt's Spiele, das kannst du dann vorab nicht analysieren. Und da bin ich wieder bei dem Thema Perturbationen. Die Ursachen zu finden, warum es zu einer Gleichgewichtsstörung kommt, sozusagen. Das ist oftmals völlig fern von dem, was man vielleicht dann vorab analysiert hat und hat auch dann oftmals vielleicht mit dem Fußball zu tun. Das steht völlig außer Frage. Deswegen ist auch die Spielanalyse, die Taktik, ist ein Mosaikbaustein, der ein Stück weit die gesamte Leistungsfähigkeit ausmacht. Zur Leistungsfähigkeit an dem Tag, speziell von einer Mannschaft, gehören tatsächlich noch viele, viele andere Dinge dazu. Aber auch die kann ich nicht alle kontrollieren. Das sich der jetzt von der Freundin trennt, das werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht verhindern können.
Das könnte auch sein, dass es sie stärker macht, je nachdem, wie es gelaufen ist. Man kann es aber nicht sagen. Dann lass mal, weil wir jetzt wieder in den selben Themenbereich reingerutschen, dann lass mal bei dem bleiben, wo man sagen kann, das kann man sehr gut analysieren. Ich würde mit dir gerne über Standard-Situationen im Fußball sprechen. Das ist tatsächlich auch eins der großen Mirakele, was ich immer auf der Stirn habe. Ich meine, ich bin jetzt auch emotional dem FC Bayern sehr nahe und es tut mir im Herz weh, Ecken der Bayern zu sehen. Ich hoffe, dass das jetzt besser wird mit Mats Hummels, dass man da vielleicht mal wieder ein paar an den kurzen Pfosten spielt und das ist dann schwierig zu verteidigen. So hat man ja auch mal die Champions League verloren. Aber ich habe den Eindruck, bis auf die Unterscheidung, ob man da mit Raum oder mit Mannendeckung spielt, oder viele spielen mit einer Mischform. Das heißt, ich nehme die gefährlichsten Gegenspieler in die Mannendeckung und die restlichen Verteidiger von meiner Mannschaft stehen im Raum, weil es auch besser ist für die Spieleröffnung, wenn man den Ball gewinnt. Aber davon abgesehen habe ich den Eindruck, es tut sich auf diesem Gebiet nichts. Warum ist das denn so? Denn das ist doch das Einzige, was ich immer wieder unter fast laborhaften Bedingungen trainieren kann.
Ja, ich kann es aber sowohl trainieren, dass ich ein Tor erziele, aber ich kann es auch laborhaft trainieren, dass ich es verhindern kann.
Okay, deswegen ist es so schwierig?
Nein, weiß ich nicht. Fakt ist, da gebe ich dir recht, 25 bis 40 Prozent der Tore entstehen daraus. Punkt. Das ist eine Hausmarke. Genau. Das ist richtig. Die Bayern haben es letztes Jahr deutlich besser gemacht. Sie haben hinten raus auch – ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, welches Spiel es war, es war ein Auswärtsspiel in der Champions League, ich glaube es war das Viertelfinale – entschieden durch so eine Standardsituation. Da hat sich schon auch was getan. Beim DFB hat sich auch was getan. Genau, das kann gut sein. Eine Zeit lang wurde darauf vielleicht weniger Wert gelegt, und man hat bei der Europameisterschaft definitiv Muster gesehen, mit denen man versucht hat, hier gefährlicher zu werden. Ich glaube schon, dass es eine Rolle spielt, und gleichzeitig ist es aber auch nicht immer so einfach. Weil ich jetzt beispielsweise als Mannschaft, die unterlegen ist, würde meinen Spielern mit auf den Weg geben, Freunde, wenn die uns jetzt auszwirbeln und ausspielen, dann sind sie vielleicht besser bei einer Standardsituation. Also da lassen wir nichts zu.
Aber andererseits, da finde ich übrigens die Unterscheidung zwischen Männerfußball und Frauenfußball total interessant, denn bei Frauen sieht man noch viel, viel mehr Varianten der angreifenden Mannschaft bei Eckbällen. Also früher hat man oft gesehen, dass ich sich auf die Torhüterin draufgestellt habe, weil die in der Regel nicht so groß waren. Und tatsächlich hat das bei – also ich spreche jetzt viel von Turnieren, Vereinsfußball kriege ich nicht so viel mit bei den Frauen – und tatsächlich hat das gut funktioniert. Jetzt bei der aktuellen – bei Olympia hat man zum Beispiel gesehen, dass es, ich glaube, zwei, vielleicht sogar drei Mannschaften gab. Und die Deutschen haben das auch bei einigen der Ecken gemacht, dass alle Spieler sich am langen Fünfer Eck positioniert haben und dann erst in dem Moment, wo der Ball in der Luft war, dann fächerförmig aufgeteilt haben. Warum sehe ich denn solche Muster nicht seltener? Oder auch dieses klassische, dass Spieler, Knoil, alle Spieler der eigenen Mannschaft stehen so eng beieinander, dass sie nicht in Manndeckung genommen werden können und explodieren dann quasi in dem Moment, wo der Ball in der Luft ist. Warum sieht man sowas so selten?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich kann es dir nicht beantworten. Ich glaube, wenn ich es jetzt mal einordnen möchte, hat das ja mit Ballbesitzfußball zu tun. Weil ich habe den Ball. Und wie will ich da jetzt Kapital drausschlagen? Ich glaube, dass das insgesamt noch ein bisschen kreativer werden kann. Und für mich ist Taktik sehr nah an Kreativität. Weil ich mir Lösungen überlege, mit denen ich im Vorteil bin. Und jetzt bei einer Ecke zum Beispiel die Beispiele, die du genannt hast. Oder ich bloque jemanden frei oder ähnliches, was man schon immer wieder sieht.
Müller gegen Brasilien, das 1 zu 0. Klose wunderbar freigeblockt.
Zum Beispiel, das hat man auch bei der Europameisterschaft häufig gesehen. Ich denke auch, dass da Potenzial da ist. Ich denke, dass insgesamt im Erspielen von Toren und Torschossen einfach Potenzial da ist. Wo ich mir einfach kreative Möglichkeiten überlegen muss. Wie will ich jetzt vielleicht für einen Überraschungseffekt sorgen? Warum lässt sich nicht einer meiner Spieler aus dem zentralen Mittelfeld mal ganz in die Spitze fallen oder auf die Seite fallen oder was weiß ich? Und das resultiert in verschiedenen Positionswechseln und so. Und das sind so Punkte, die mir teilweise einfach noch so ein bisschen fehlen. Vielleicht geht es auch mir nur so, weil ich das gerne sehe, weil ich auch gerne Muster erkenne, weil dann kann ich welche erkennen.
Ja, Herr Schmink, wir sind beide Freunde von Hussein, das kann man schon sagen.
Vielleicht kommt es aus der Schiene, aber gleichzeitig ist es halt so, dass ich gegen die mittlerweile sehr gut verteidigenden Mannschaften, egal ob bei der Ecke oder im freien Spiel, einfach die Möglichkeit habe, für Räume für mich zu sorgen und da gewisse Zielspieler in gewisse Zielräume zu bringen. Nichts anderes hat Guardiola gemacht. Das war im Grunde immer ein ähnlicher Ansatz. Es ging um die zwei äußeren Spieler, Ribéry, Robben, wie sie alle hießen. Und alles, was vorher passierte, waren immer wieder mal Positionswechsel. Ziel war aber eigentlich immer, diese Spieler dort in vorteilhafte Situationen zu bringen. Und dazu muss ich aber auch den Mut haben, dass ich den Ball haben will. Wenn ich den Ball habe, dann steigert das mein Fehlerpotenzial.
Und ich muss die Spieler haben, die das können. Also mit dem Bayern jetzt den Ball haben zu wollen, ist weniger mutig als mit dem HSV zum Beispiel. Die haben auch recht viel tatsächlich den Ball haben.
Das stimmt. Da gebe ich dir erstmal recht. Und Bayern ist da immer ein Extrembeispiel. Aber ich meine, alle anderen sind Bundesligaspieler. Also die haben ein Niveau. Und zwar ein ganz schönes Niveau, dass die da oben in der Bundesliga kicken. Und ich glaube, dass da teilweise noch mehr rauszuholen ist. Und vielleicht macht sogar den Spieler manchmal noch ein bisschen mehr Spaß, wenn sie den Ball am Fuß haben und ihm nicht die ganze Zeit hinterherlaufen müssen.
Ja, hinter dieser These würde ich auch stehen. Auch aus meiner persönlichen sehr, sehr leidenhaften Fußballerfahrung ist es einfach besser, wenn man den Ball hat, alles andere nervt. Und dann fällt einem jeder Meter, dem man läuft, noch viel, viel mehr auf. Wenn man den Ball hinterher sprinten kann, dann läuft man nochmal den extra Kilometer, dem man nie gejoggt wäre. Genau so ist es. Das heißt, um diese Frage kreisen wir jetzt eigentlich schon seit einiger Zeit, dass wir beide feststellen, der Fußball hat sich dahingehend entwickelt, dass das Verteidigen sehr, sehr gut ausgearbeitet ist, das Arbeiten gegen den Ball. Was erwartest du denn jetzt für Entwicklungen dann im Spiel mit dem Ball?
Also ich glaube, wie gesagt, ich glaube, dass das Thema Kreativität eine große Rolle spielt. Also man hat auch gesehen, wie sich Dortmund entwickelt hat. Da hatten wir vorher mal angesprochen, da sind einfach immer wieder neue Lösungsmöglichkeiten dazu gekommen. Bestes Beispiel ist so die Renaissance auch der Dreierkette, die jetzt irgendwie auch wieder aufkam. Weil man, wenn man eine Dreierkette spielt und damit das Spiel eröffnet, dann habe ich halt gewisse Vorteile, wie wenn ich jetzt mit der Viererkette spiele. Und solche Entwicklungen, glaube ich, werden immer wieder kommen. Und ich glaube, dass sich Systeme immer wieder mal verändern. Ich glaube, dass wir mittlerweile sehr viel über den Fußball wissen. Also ich glaube, dass da wirklich sehr viel geforscht wurde. Ich glaube, dass mittlerweile sehr genau auf alles geschaut wird. Und ich glaube aber trotzdem, dass immer wieder neue Ideen hinzukommen, wie man gewisse Positionen einsetzen kann. Bestes Beispiel, auch wieder Guardiola oder auch Löw. Plötzlich tauchen die Außenverteidiger im Zentrum auf. So, dadurch, dass der Außenverteidiger ins Zentrum geht, habe ich plötzlich eine Überzahl im Zentrum. Naja, dann spiele ich halt übers Zentrum. Oder der Gegenspieler vom Außenverteidiger sagt, hä, scheiße, mein Gegenspieler läuft ins Zentrum hinterher. Naja, und plötzlich geht der Raum auf der Außenbahn auf. Und das sind die Dinge, um die mir es persönlich geht, die ich auch cool finde dann, weil man sich da einfach was einfallen lässt, um dem Gegner dann einen Schritt voraus zu sein.
Und trotzdem würde ich sagen, obwohl die Spieler heutzutage viel, viel besser ausgebildet sind als noch vor 15 Jahren, also da muss man glaube ich nicht lange drüber diskutieren, das erkennt man, wenn man sich Bundesligaspiele anguckt, finde ich, dass diese aktuelle Entwicklung ein paar Mannschaften, die eine sehr hohe individuelle Klasse haben, bevorteit gegenüber anderen Mannschaften. Also ich glaube einfach, dass es viel, viel schwieriger ist, diese kreativen Lösungen, die am Reißbrett wunderbar sind, aber die ja immer noch auf den Rasen gebracht werden müssen. Ich glaube, dass das für Mannschaften wie Dortmund, wie Bayern, jetzt auch Schalke und da weiß ich, da bin ich total gespannt, was sich verändert, Gladbach sowieso, für die ist das viel, viel einfacher umzusetzen. Und deswegen habe ich so ein bisschen die Sorge ehrlich gesagt, dass die Schere zwischen den Mannschaften das Leistungsgefälle noch ein bisschen auseinandergeht.
Das sehe ich nicht so ehrlich gesagt. Ich finde, das – und das hat mir meine persönliche Erfahrung gezeigt – dass wenn du ein entsprechendes Funktionsteam hast, das heißt wirklich auch mit einem Chef-Trainer, der offen dafür ist, mit einem Co-Trainer-Team, wo dann zum Beispiel auch der Co-Trainer-Analyse dazugehört, wenn ihr da gut arbeitet, wenn du eine klare Spielkonzeption hast, dann kannst du auch bei einer Mannschaft, die vielleicht sehr jung ist und die erstmal auf dem Papier der anderen unterlegen ist, denen Vorteile erarbeiten, weil dir vielleicht eigentlich sonst auch nichts übrig bleibt.
Das heißt, man braucht Special-Coaches, so wie in der NFL so ein bisschen?
Ja, Special-Coaches, wie man sie nennt, sei dahingestellt. Aber ja, Spezial-Trainer, klar, in jedem Fall. Ich glaube auch, dass das die Entwicklung weiterbringen wird, dass man Spezial-Trainer hat. Und wir haben ja schon Spezial-Trainer. Wir haben den Athletiktrainer. Wir haben dann die Physiotherapeuten. Wir haben den Torwarttrainer. Und wir haben mittlerweile auch einfach den Co-Trainer Analyse zum Beispiel. Und seine Aufgabe kann ja genau so was sein, in Zusammenarbeit mit dem Trainerteam diese Dinge zu entwickeln. Und natürlich wird es dann der Verein X vielleicht nicht gegen Dortmund oder Bayern spielen, weil dann vielleicht die Schere doch zu weit auseinandergeht. Aber gegen Mannschaften, die halt einem ungefähr auf einem Leistungsniveau begegnen, kann ich einen riesen Vorteil haben. Und das ist der Grund, warum ich da immer sage, okay, ist das vielleicht keine Ausrede?
Ich will dir ja sehr gerne glauben. Meine Ansicht ist die deprimierendere Ansicht. Andererseits habe ich auch manchmal den Eindruck, dass alles braucht Zeit. Und Zeit ist, glaube ich, das kostbarste Gut gerade im Profifußball. Und diese Zeit bekommt man heutzutage aber auch oft nicht mehr gerade, weil es so erfolgsgetrieben ist. Also ich finde ein hervorragendes, weil Positivbeispiel ist da der erste FC Köln-Unterstöger, der aus der zweiten Liga hochgekommen ist, dann das Spielsystem krass auf Defensive ausgelegt hat und der sich jetzt schrittweise in jeder der Bundesligaspielzeiten mehr dem Ballbesitzspiel, dem Offensivspiel zugewandt hat und es wurde von Saison zu Saison besser. Aber hätte das in der ersten Saison nicht hingehauen oder wäre es in der zweiten Saison schiefgegangen, dann hätte es gut sein können, dass Stöger weg ist und dann ist diese fortgeschritten Entwicklung weg. Und dann kommt vielleicht jemand mit einer anderen Idee.
Absolut. Ich finde es ein super cooles Beispiel, ehrlich gesagt. Es trifft genau auf den Punkt. Aber das ist dann leider auch der Profifußball, in dem der Erfolg einfach mit dabei sein muss. Sonst musst du halt wieder gehen. Außer du bist vielleicht auch in einem Verein, der diese Entwicklung ein Stück weit mittragen will. Wobei die harte Frage ist, nur weil ich jetzt einen guten Fußballspiel und vielleicht genau die Dinge umsetze, bin ich vielleicht nicht gleichzeitig sportlich erfolgreicher. Das ist ja immer dieses Rad, in dem wir uns befinden. Deswegen ist es auch ein gesunder Mittelweg, sich auch nicht zu stark in eine Prozessorientierung zu verfallen. Das heißt, sich nicht nur auf den Prozess zu konzentrieren, was ich jetzt alles machen kann und wie kreativ ich sein kann. Und sobald ich dann von mir aus an der gegnerischen Grundlinie angekommen bin, dann feiere ich mich, weil ich sage, diese Art und Weise wie ich es jetzt schon seit Wochen im Training trainiere, ich bringe halt wieder die Flanke und sie geht hinter das Tor. Das ist für mich dann die falsche Prozessorientierung, wo man halt dann auch wieder sehr starke Zielorientierung braucht und sagt, ok, das Ziel ist ein Tor zu machen. Und wenn ich aus 30 Metern schieße und der dreimal abgefälscht ist, zufälligerweise, naja, dann ist er drin und ich gewinne das Spiel 1 zu 0.
So, das Bayern mal gegen Chelsea ausgeschieden. Im Hin und im Rückspiel hat Lucio einen Fernschuss abgefälscht. Felix Maggert war das noch. Ich glaube, das war auch in der Saison, wo er dann gehen musste, weil er nur das Dugel geholt hat. Schlimme Zeiten für die Bayern waren das damals. Ich finde, wir haben jetzt schon mehrfach einen auch noch wichtigen Aspekt angesprochen, über den du auch allein schon aufgrund deiner Vita sehr gut Bescheid weißt. Wir saßen jetzt quasi virtuell die ganze Zeit vom Laptop und haben uns Spiele angeguckt und vom Reißbrett. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie kriege ich das ins Training rein? Also wir haben jetzt, sagen wir einfach mal, drei kleine Portionen, wo wir uns gesagt haben, ok, der Matchplan für das nächste Spiel wird diese drei Elemente beinhalten. Wer übernimmt eigentlich dann im Trainerstab die Aufgabe, das in Übung umzusetzen? Ist das eine Chef-Trainer-Sache? Welche Rolle spielen da die Co-Trainer?
Total unterschiedlich. Also das wird verschiedenste gehandhabt, angefangen von der Lösung, dass jetzt der Analyst, sage ich mal, gar nicht in die Trainingsgestaltung involviert ist, sondern eben nur seine Erkenntnisse weitergibt, vielleicht auch nochmal diskutiert. Und das Trainerteam, das dann umsetzt, bis hin zum anderen Extrem, dass der Co-Trainer-Analyse sozusagen dann auch die Erkenntnisse mit dem Cheftrainer und dem Trainerteam bespricht und sie dann auch vielleicht sogar selbst auf dem Platz mit umsetzt in Form von Trainingsübungen. Das hängt natürlich immer von der Arbeitsweise ab.
Wie hat sich denn da die Trainingswissenschaft entwickelt und ist das ein Teil auch jetzt zum Beispiel eurer Zertifikatausbildung? Ich würde fast sagen, das ist so ein bisschen die Kühe. Die Spielanalyse, das ist wichtig und das ist fordernd, das ist auch nicht leicht. Aber die Kühe ist ja dann eigentlich mit den einzelnen Bits, die ich mir da rausgezogen habe, das dann quasi wieder auf den Rasen zu bringen.
Richtig, der letzte elementare Schritt, für den man eigentlich alles vorher macht. Im Zertifikat haben wir es drinnen, ja. Wobei, wie gesagt, das sind einfach Dinge, die dann einfach auch in Kompetenzen übergehen, die zum Beispiel halt einfach einen Trainer haben muss, wo man sehr nah zum Beispiel dann auch an der Fußballlehrerausbildung ist, wo es darum geht, die Inhalte, die man nun hat, in trainingspraktische Maßnahmen umzusetzen und zu sehen, wie weit bin ich denn schon mit meinem Leistungsstand? Also muss ich anfangen und einen 8 oder 9 gegen 0 spielen, um einfach die Laufwege zum Beispiel einzuschleifen und zu üben? Oder kann ich schon den Gegner mit dazu nehmen, fiktiv, der dann zum Beispiel am Wochenende halt meinen Gegner simuliert und dem sein System spielt? Wie weit bin ich da? Und dann kann man da natürlich sehr methodische Schritte auch gehen, um das Ganze ins Training umzusetzen. Wer das macht, wie gesagt, das ist etwas, was verschiedenste gehandhabt wird.
Thomas Tuchel sagt ja immer – oder hat zumindest gesagt – It's not a coach's game, it's a player's game. Das spricht ja jetzt gegen viel über das wir gesprochen haben oder nicht.
Also ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, dass ein wesentliches Ziel der Spielanalyse ist, seine eigenen Spieler stärker zu machen.
Jürgen Klinsmann, Vorreiter.
Auf eine gewisse Weise ganz bestimmt, klar. Ich bin immer gerne bei dem Beispiel Gegneranalyse, weil das sehr greifbar ist. Ich will ja im Grunde nichts anderes als meine Mannschaft auf den kommenden Gegner einzustellen. Da bin ich ja direkt beim Spieler. Ich will mich ja nicht selber abfeiern, weil ich eine coole Analyse gemacht habe, die eigentlich den Spielern nicht interessiert. Das ist so der eine Punkt. Der zweite Punkt ist der, dass man natürlich auch vieles machen kann, um die Stärken der einzelnen Spieler hervorzuheben. Wir hatten vorher das Beispiel Guardiola mit Robben und Ribéry. Wenn ich meine Mannschaft gut kenne, wenn ich weiß, was die Stärken sind, dann versuche ich diese natürlich auch immer wieder zu provozieren. Das kann ich dann, wenn ich weiß, wie der Gegner agiert, weil ich wissen muss, wie verteidigt er zum Beispiel. Und dann kann ich das Ganze umsetzen. Und klar, es kommt ein wesentlicher Punkt noch dazu. Das ist der Bereich Individualität, den vor allem im Profifußball weit verbreitet ist. Wo Persönlichkeiten rumlaufen, die dann auch nicht immer einfach zu haben sind bei den Spielern, das ist völlig klar. Und die gilt es aber da auch irgendwie einzufangen und im besten Fall stark zu machen. Und vielleicht auch mal aus dem System, aus dem Taktischen völlig rauszulassen. Wer weiß, da gibt es ja verschiedene Lösungsansätze. Und deswegen stimme ich mit dem Zitat von Herrn Tuchel erstmal auch völlig überein.
Wie würdest du sagen, hat sich so die Spielegeneration verändert? Ich meine, du hast ja einen relativ nahen Blick auf die Entwicklung in den letzten Jahren. Man sagt ja immer, dass es kein Zufall ist, dass jetzt auch die heutigen Nationalspieler eher die Generation ist, die auch Abitur gemacht hat, begleitend zur Fußballausbildung und so weiter. Und ich möchte es jetzt nicht nur auf so platte Bildungsdinge reduzieren, aber es ist ja schon eine eloquente Spielergeneration, eine taktisch gut geschulte Spielergeneration durch die Entwicklung in den Nachwuchsleistungszentren innerhalb der letzten Jahre. Was glaubst du, hat sich da so in den letzten Jahren verändert?
Ja, ich glaube schon genau das, was du angesprochen hast. Und das macht es im Übrigen auch heutzutage sehr schwierig für den Trainer, für den Cheftrainer im Profifußball.
Macht es nicht leichter, weil er hinterfragt wird oder warum?
Also es macht es ihm vielleicht erstmal leichter, weil er Spieler kriegt, die ihm wahrscheinlich extrem gut ausgebildet sind. Oder streichen wir das wahrscheinlich, sie sind extrem gut ausgebildet. Fakt ist aber auch, dass natürlich diese Ausbildung, die die Spieler hatten, hat er zwangsläufig zur Folge, dass sie unfassbar gute Trainer hatten, die auch schon taktisch sehr, sehr gut geschult waren. Und da gibt es, denke ich, in den deutschen Nachwuchsleistungszentren einige. Und als Cheftrainer musst du natürlich auch nochmal einen draufsetzen, inhaltlicher Natur und taktischer Natur, was, glaube ich, heutzutage gar nicht mehr so einfach ist. Interessante Aspekt. Klar hat die Trainerrolle auch viel mit anderen Aspekten zu tun. Nicht nur mit Taktischen, sondern es geht viel um Führung. Du musst deinen ganzen Stab führen, du musst die Mannschaft führen und so. Das ist schon auch eine ganz besondere Rolle und Aufgabe. Aber das ist, glaube ich, auch nicht immer einfach für den Trainer. Ich weiß jetzt bloß nicht, ob ich damit eine Frage beantwortet habe.
Na ja, im Grunde schon, dadurch, dass wir uns einig sind, dass sich die Spieler in en gros quasi verändert haben in ihrer Auffassungsgabe und in ihrer Schulung. Die Anschlussfrage, die sich da für mich so ein bisschen stellt, ist, in diesem Bereich der Spielerausbildung hat ja auch der DFB eine maßgebliche Rolle gespielt. Also 2000 wird immer so als Stunde Null im deutschen Fußball bezeichnet. Dann gab es die Einführung der Nachwuchsleistungszentren. Es wurde verpflichtend, dass auch die Bundesligisten Nachwuchsleistungszentren hatten. Es gab einen gewissen Goldstandard, den man erreichen konnte. So wurde das peu à peu in der Bundesliga etabliert. Nicht nur die Engländer schauen jetzt sehr neidisch hier rüber, was für eine Spielergeneration wir jetzt haben, sondern auch die Franzosen, die ja selbst ein sehr gutes Nachwuchsleistungskonzept haben. Auch die gucken immer wieder nach Deutschland und schauen, wie hat das der DFB eigentlich zusammen mit der DFL hinbekommen. Und gleichzeitig setzt man aber natürlich dann dadurch, dass die Trainer ja alle dieselbe Schule durchlaufen haben, nämlich den DFB-Fußballlehrer, die Ausbildung, setzt man ja auch so ein paar Grundfundamente, wie man Fußball spielt, wie man über Fußball denkt. Und ich habe so den Eindruck, dass jetzt fast die interessantesten Spieler aktuell welche sind, die nicht in das Raster der normalen Spieler reinpassen. Also wenn wir es vielleicht mal an einem Beispiel machen wollen, nicht nur bei der Europameisterschaft hieß es, ja uns fehlt halt vielleicht mal jemand, der auch mal im 1 gegen 1 ein Tripling gewinnt oder der mal etwas Verrücktes probiert, das was Franck Ribéry seit Jahren beim FC Bayern macht. Das ist für mich so ein kleines Indiz für das, was ich vorher ausgeführt habe. Siehst du es ähnlich?
Also ich glaube erstmal, dass man, finde ich, nicht sagen kann, dass wenn dieselbe Schule durchlaufen wird, dass dasselbe Wissen und dasselbe Denken bedeutet. Ich glaube, dass es einfach Fundamente im Fußball gibt. Die verändern sich nicht. Die verändern sich auch in anderen Ländern nicht. Und so wie ich die Fußballlehrerausbildung kennengelernt habe, auch wenn ich sie nicht selber gemacht habe, aber da schon immer viel mitgekriegt habe, dann geht es da schon auch sehr viel um Selbstreflektion und sich selbst weiterzuentwickeln, inhaltlich, so wie eben auch als Trainer. Wo eben nicht irgendwas nach dem Motto hingeschoben wird, so ist es und fertig. Ich glaube, das ist auch ein wichtiger Ansatz. Deswegen finde ich eigentlich die Art und Weise, wie man davor geht, sehr gut. Nichtsdestotrotz hat man es jetzt auch ein bisschen gemerkt, dass schon ähnliche Spielertypen zuletzt immer aus dem Nachwuchsleistungszentrum so ein bisschen rausploppten, die dann auch zum Star wurden und in der Nationalmannschaft drankamen. Ich glaube aber auch, dass das vielleicht eine relativ normale Entwicklung ist. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass man eigentlich immer auch nach den großen Turnieren lächzte man nach gewissen Positionen. Ich kann mich erinnern, es war eine Zeit lang eben genau der kreative Mittelfeldspieler, der uns dann gefehlt hat, der jetzt aber vielfach eben ausgebildet wurde, weil man da vielleicht einen besonderen Fokus drauf gelegt hat. Und jetzt fehlen uns halt vielleicht wieder andere Spieler. Und da fehlt auch der Mittelstürmer zum Beispiel, der eine große Rolle in dem Zusammenhang spielt. Deswegen ist es vielleicht so ein normaler Prozess. Gleichzeitig kann es aber auch, denke ich, für die Nachwuchsleistungszentren sensibilisieren, eben zu versuchen, keine Raster auszubilden, sondern da wirklich auch eine Freiheit zu lassen und die verschiedenen Positionsprofile, die halt existieren, auch auszubilden.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen eine provokante Frage. Aber meinst du, dass diese Gleichförmigkeit der Spiele, die jetzt in die Nationalmannschaft geschafft haben, dass es auch ein bisschen damit zu tun hat, wie über Fußball heutzutage berichtet wird und wie wahrscheinlich auch wir zwei über Fußball urteilen? Also ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, in den letzten Jahren ging es sehr, sehr krass um Fehlerminimierung, weil es tatsächlich irgendwann so war, wenn vorne der Rechtsaußen im 1 gegen 1 den Ball verloren hat und daraufhin gab es die Umscheißsituation des Gegentor, dann war das vielleicht vor zehn Jahren noch so, dass nicht alle mit dem Finger auf den Rechtsaußen gezeigt haben, weil man damals noch ein bisschen einen anderen Blick hatte. Heutzutage kann man sich aber schon ziemlich sicher sein, dass auch in der Massenbilderberichterstattung, dass schon thematisiert wird, da vorne war der Ballverlust. Deswegen habe ich so den Eindruck, es ging immer mehr darum, keine Fehler zu machen, damit man nicht im Fokus der Öffentlichkeit steht.
Ja, das ist eine These. Ich finde zunächst, diese Gleichförmigkeit, die du angesprochen hast, wenn man sie positiv auslegt, dann sind es Spezialisten, die man ausgebildet hat. Spezialisten auf ihren Positionen, zum Beispiel Außenverteidiger. Ein Kimmich, der ausgebildet wurde jetzt, der vielleicht auch an Philipp Lahm erinnert, ist erstmal jemand, der unfassbar viele Attribute mitbringt, wo man sagt, hey, das ist das, was wir suchen als Außenverteidiger, der jetzt auch in Norwegen das Tor gemacht hat, sodass diese Gleichförmigkeit, also diese Ausbildung von Spezialisten, für mich erstmal nichts Schlechtes ist. Das hat ja auch einen positiven Aspekt. Und den anderen Aspekt, den du genannt hast, ist da sehr viel von den Medien getragen. Ich finde es schwer zu beurteilen, ehrlich gesagt. Fehlervermeidung, ja. Auf der anderen Seite – und da kann ich es eigentlich wieder runterbrechen – auch Fehlervermeidung ist Spiel gegen den Ball. Vielleicht ist es der Grund, warum das viele Mannschaften sehr intensiv machen, weil sie eben dann keine Fehler machen können, weil sie den Ball nicht haben. Wenn du den Ball hast, dann bist du mutig und kannst halt Fehler machen. Aber es ist ja auch so, dass Spieler, die 15 Mal was versuchen, mehr Fehler machen werden, als Spieler, die nur fünf Mal was versuchen. Das finde ich einen schwierigen Punkt. Ich würde mir eigentlich wünschen, dass die Medien – und eigentlich schließe ich mich da ein bisschen ein, weil ich bin ja im Grunde auch tätig für Medien – dass man da vielleicht dem Ganzen ein bisschen positiver gegenübersteht. Und auch ein Mario Götze, der unfassbar in der Kritik gerade ist, auch von Jens Lehmann, der ja ganz schön eine Schelte gekriegt hat, dass man das ein bisschen analytischer angeht. Und wenn wir von Ursachen sprechen, auch die tatsächlichen Ursachen versuchen zu finden. Du hast zum Beispiel Ballverlust angesprochen und dann wirklich auch auf die Fehlerkette eingehen, die dahinter steckt und nicht nur dieses eine finden wollen.
Ja gut, letztlich landen wir dann bei einem generellen Problem. Es ist immer einfacher zu verkürzen und das ist auch die spitzere Schlagzeile. Mario Götz ist ja das perfekte Beispiel. Bevor er sich bei den Bayern verletzt hat, das war die Phase, wo eigentlich alle, auch die Mainstream-Medien geschrieben hatten, er scheint angekommen zu sein. Da hat er in der Champions League mehrere entscheidende Tore gespielt. Da hatte er seinen festen Platz in der Mannschaft. Da waren zwar auch noch ein paar andere Spieler verletzt, aber er hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt einen absoluten Stammplatz. Dann hat er sich verletzt und als er zurückkam, waren andere Spieler wieder fit. Er hat dann nicht mehr in der entscheidenden Saisonphase den Weg in die Mannschaft gefunden. Dann ist es aber natürlich die größere Schlagzeile zu sagen, Götze bei Bayern endgültig gescheitert, als zu sagen, er hat jetzt auch einfach ein bisschen Pech gehabt. Das ist für Guardiola auch schwierig, in einem Champions League-Viertelfinale, was spitz auf Knopf steht, und in einem Halbfinale Götze reinzuschmeißen. Es ist schon ein Fakt, dass er es nicht getan hat. Darüber kann ich berichten. Aber verstehst du, was ich meine? Das, was wir uns wünschen würden, sind Grautöne, aber die sind halt auch langweiliger. Das ist halt kein Schwarz oder kein Weiß.
Ja klar, und Fußball ist einfach da auch unglaublich schnelllebig. Wenn er jetzt drei Hütten macht in den nächsten drei Spielen, dann ist er mal kurz einfach wieder der King. Dann interessiert einen das, was vorher war, nicht mehr. Deswegen, glaube ich, ist eher die Frage, wie geht der Spieler Mario Götze einfach damit um, mit diesen Medien? Klar ist, dass das an keiner menschlichen Person einfach mal so vorbeigeht. Also es tangiert ihn in irgendeiner Form mit Sicherheit. Ich hoffe nur, dass es nicht zu sehr ist, dass er einfach aus diesem Leistungstief so wieder rauskommt.
Okay, wir wollen es jetzt auch gar nicht auf Mario Götze hier reduzieren. Mich befällt da ein fast körperliches Unbehagen, weil ich nicht nahe genug an den Spielern dran bringe. Da mache ich dann immer ganz schnell auch in der Schlusskonferenz dicht. Da muss man jetzt einfach gucken, was er auf den Platz bringt. Dafür muss man ihn aber auch noch zehn Spiele mehr spielen lassen, als die paar, die jetzt gespielt sind in dieser Saison.
Taktisch muss ich dann schon noch mal für ihn in die Presse springen. Ich will ihn nicht verteidigen oder ähnliches. Das ist ganz neutral, aber die Art und Weise der Länderspiele, wie sie zuletzt liefen, ist halt auch einfach überhaupt nicht sein Spiel, wenn er auf der Position gespielt hat. Und selbst wenn er vielleicht weiter außen gespielt hat, wo er unfassbar wenig Platz hatte, auch immer gegen diese tiefstehenden Gegner, das ist jetzt keine Neuigkeit. Davon redet man auch regelmäßig. Aber man muss diesen Faktor halt auch mit einbeziehen. Und es geht anderen Spielern ja genauso. Es geht einem Draxler genauso. Und ein Thomas Müller hat auch richtig Stress gehabt, weil er so wenig Raum hatte usw. usf. Und dann ist die Frage ja, dann ist halt mal wieder ein Zufall da. Und dann steht er halt mal wieder richtig. Das sind dann auch so Sachen, die sind dann völlig ungreifbar. Aber wenn wir es jetzt taktisch begründen, dann muss man jetzt auch erst mal wieder abwarten, bis er in einem System eingesetzt wird, das ihm halt auch liegt.
Das stimmt. Und richtiger Punkt auch mit dem Zufall. Ich meine, Deutschland gegen Norwegen, Norwegen liegt nur zu eins hinten, steht immer noch 20 Meter vor dem Tor mit neun Mann. Alles ist wahnsinnig eng, da ist es total schwierig für Götze. Und ich kann mich noch erinnern, ein Beispiel in die andere Richtung. Deutschland gegen Italien 4 zu 1 hier in München. Alle sagen, Götze hat wieder ein Tor gemacht, er ist einfach bei der Nationalmannschaft, führte sich zu Hause. Und das Tor war das untypischste Götze-Tor aller Zeiten. Das war eine No-Look-Flanke von Thomas Müller. Und er macht zwischen Bonucci und Cellini, glaube ich, ein Kopfballtor. Also überhaupt nichts, wo man sagen kann, er fühlt sich so zu Hause, sondern ja, halt zweimal Zufall. Damit sind wir ja schon eigentlich recht weit in dem Bereich der Frage, was für eine Medienberichterstattung man sich so wünschen könnte. Wir haben es immer schon wieder ein bisschen gestriffen, aber ein Bereich, der mich noch interessiert, ist die Terminologie. Gerade weil es jetzt so ist, dass es eben auch viele Autodidakten gibt, wie ja zum Beispiel auch mich, habe ich den Eindruck, dass manchmal ein bisschen aneinander vorbei geredet wird. Wie wichtig ist denn eine einheitliche Terminologie? Wie kann man die sich drauf schaffen?
Er ist tatsächlich unfassbar wichtig. Also in der Vereinsarbeit sowieso. Also da gibt es auch genügend Beispiele, in denen ein Vokabular wirklich festgelegt wird, dass ganz klar ist, was man unter was versteht, dass man eine Sprache spricht, dass man vielleicht sogar auch mit Zeichensprache mal an der Seitenlinie, weil es im Stadion halt so saulaut ist, mal kurz eine Info geben kann, ohne dass man drei Sätze irgendwie versucht, über 20 Meter zu schreiben.
Die berühmten Finger von Lucien Favre, zwei Zeigefinger, war glaube ich, dass er auf Viererkette umgestellt hat, wenn ich mich nicht verinner.
Und deswegen im Verein unabdingbar und entwickelt sich auch und kann man auch als teambildende Maßnahme mal einsetzen. Ich finde, in den Medien kann man das durchaus auch. Wobei es da schon schwierig ist, weil es einfach allein aufgrund der unterschiedlichen Arten des Sprechens in Deutschland schon unterschiedliche Wörter benutzt werden. Torhüter, Torspieler, Torwart. Das ist so ein Beispiel, das wird einfach unterschiedlich eingesetzt. Und da gibt es dann noch viel tiefere taktische Begriffe.
Aber da weiß ich ja, was gemeint ist.
Ja, das stimmt, dann war das jetzt vielleicht ein super banales Beispiel. Aber es gibt andere Begriffe, die einfach unterschiedlich verwendet werden können. Auf der anderen Seite glaube ich, ist es jetzt nicht zwingend notwendig, das zu vereinheitlichen für den gesamten Medienbetrieb sozusagen. Aber ich glaube auch, dass wenn man… wenn man… Wenn man jetzt von einem Sender oder ähnliches spricht, der seine Berichterstattung macht, glaube ich, ist es schon von Vorteil, dass man so grundlegende, untergrundlegende Dinge wirklich auch dasselbe versteht.
Was ich mir ja wünschen würde bei der Fußballberichterstattung ist, ich hätte gern einmal die Formation der Mannschaft mit dem Ball und einmal gegen den Ball. Ich frage mich, warum das nicht kommt. Jetzt, wenn die Mannschaftsausstellung gezeigt wird, manchmal finde ich es sogar geradezu witzig, wenn bei Gegnern der Bayern gezeigt wird, dass sie ganz toll in einem 4-2-3-1 stehen. Aber schon nach fünf Minuten sieht man ja, die Außen lassen sich aber so weit zurückfallen, dass es eine Fünfer- und manchmal eine Sechser-Kette ist. Warum wird sowas nicht einfach gemacht? Ist das dann vielleicht auch schon eine Detail-Ebene, die tatsächlich nur uns beide hier interessiert und vielleicht die, die jetzt gerade einen Rasenfunk hören?
Also ja, eine Frage, die ich mir auch schon seit langem stelle, weil es einfach prinzipiell so ist, dass wir zwei Positionierungen haben, mit dem Ball und gegen den Ball. Auf der anderen Seite ist es aber auch so, dass ich von dieser statischen Grundordnung auch gar nicht so viel halte. Weil die haben wir im Spiel dann vielleicht mal zwei oder drei Mal, jeweils beim Anstoß, beim Gegentor so ungefähr. Und ansonsten bewegen wir uns sowieso wieder im System. Und das System verändert sich ständig. Und deswegen hat man ja dann auch immer wieder Heatmaps, wo dann Durchschnittspositionen oder Ähnliches angezeigt werden.
Die finde ich so wahnsinnig ungenau. Die sagen doch, außer bei Spielern, die einen klaren Fokus hatten, sagen diese Heatmaps nichts. Weil die Heatmaps würden dann quasi nur auf die Minutenbereiche hin viel aussagen können. Also wenn ich sagen könnte, zeig mir jetzt mal seine Bewegungs-Heatmap der ersten 15 Minuten, der nächsten 15 Minuten und so weiter. Solche Heatmaps mit so realtaktischen Positionen gibt es ja zum Beispiel von der FIFA bei der Weltmeisterschaft immer. Dann finde ich, hat das eine Aussagekraft. Aber so eine 90-Minuten-Heatmap, wo das Team einmal 0-1 hinten lag, dann das 1-1 gemacht hat und am Schluss mit 11 gegen 10 gespielt hat, bringt mir doch eine Heatmap nichts.
Ja, sehr schön. Aber jetzt hast du dich gerade deine Argumentation von ganz zu Beginn runtergekegelt, weil das sind nämlich Daten. Das sind Positionsdaten und das ist die Frage der Interpretation. Deswegen gebe ich dir recht und es gibt nicht nur die Möglichkeit, das zeitlich zu begrenzen, sondern man kann auch Spielsituationen herausfiltern. Also in denen es mich besonders interessiert, wie die Durchschnittsposition aussieht. Und mich interessiert es zum Beispiel jetzt nicht zwangsläufig, wenn ich jetzt allein unterscheide mit dem Ball und gegen den Ball, wie ist da die Durchschnittsposition? Weil da sind Momente dabei, in denen die in der völligen Unordnung sind. Sondern mich interessieren zum Beispiel Momente, in denen die mannschaftstaktisch anlaufen. Wo ich sage, okay so und jetzt agieren die aus ihrer Grundordnung 4-2-3-1, agieren die in ihrem System. Das ist der Unterschied. Grundordnung statisch, System dynamisch. Und wie bewegt sich dann dieses System sozusagen in dieser kurzen Anlaufphase, in denen zum Beispiel dann der spielt dann zwar den langen Ball oder die schaffen es irgendwie sich rauszukombinieren. Aber dann habe ich eine Information, wie die tatsächliche Positionierung eigentlich ist. Und dann bin ich auch wieder bei dem Punkt, naja, wie will ich die Daten einsetzen, sodass ich eine Information darüber kriege, was der Trainer wissen will. Und der Trainer will zum Beispiel genau solche Situationen wissen.
Ja gut, wobei wir jetzt im Bereich der Berichterstattung ein bisschen gelandet sind.
Ja, wobei das, glaube ich, in dieselbe Richtung geht.
Wobei mir jetzt zum Beispiel auch gerade schon aufgefallen ist, dass ich das Wort System anders verwende als du. Da sind wir auch schon wieder beim Terminologiebegriff. Ich spreche im System und meine damit die Grundordnung. Und du hast mir gerade gezeigt, was ja richtig ist, dass das das Dynamische ist. Jetzt muss ich ja auch gucken, dass ich das in der Schlusskonferenz immer hinkriege. Das wird was. Wir machen schon sehr lange, deswegen würde ich mal sagen, biegen wir mal so langsam auf die Zielgerade ein. Mich würde noch interessieren, mit welchen Quellen bildest du dich denn eigentlich weiter? Gibt es denn da eigentlich Literatur? Da ist das eigentlich ganz viel, dass du eben zum Beispiel mit einem Frank Wormuth Kontakt hast, dass du dich austauschen kannst. Es gibt ja auch nicht die eine richtige Wahrheit, sondern es ist ja eine ständige Diskussion. Das macht es ja auch sogar in dem Bereich so spannend. Also man kann immer über den Fußball reden, egal in welcher Detailtiefe und analytischen Tiefe man das machen will. Wie bildest du dich weiter?
Also mir ist erstmal total wichtig, da auch nochmal zu erwähnen, dass es eben tatsächlich nicht die eine Wahrheit gibt. Und all das, was ich jetzt so von meiner Seite berichtet habe, ist total subjektiv. Weil jemand anders sieht es auch wieder anders und bewertet eine Spielsituation auch vielleicht wieder anders. Und das ist auch unfassbar wichtig, sich das beizubehalten. Und ich hoffe, dass es so auch in einem Gespräch rüberkommt. Mir persönlich natürlich auch wichtig. Ich glaube, dass in der Spielanalyse und auch was Taktik betrifft, ist insgesamt der Austausch wirklich essentiell. Genau, mit meinen Kumpanen. Also was für mich ein enormer Mehrwert ist, ist tatsächlich der Austausch in den Projekten, die ich mache. Wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise Champions League Spiele analysiere, dann auch mich mit den Personen auszutauschen, für die ich es analysiere, sozusagen. Also wirklich sehr, sehr projektbezogen. Aber jetzt ist es natürlich auch so, dass ich den absoluten Luxus habe, dass ich jetzt zum zweiten Mal als Programmleiter unser Hochschulzertifikat begleiten darf. Und da haben wir absolute Top-Dozenten, wenn ich mal einfach Vollwerbung machen darf, aber es ist so, die Top-Experten in ihrem Bereich sind. Das heißt, die dozieren durch diesen Tag und gleichzeitig sind aber auch Teilnehmer da, die sich unglaublich intensiv mit dem Bereich der Spielanalyse auseinandersetzen. Und diese Interaktion macht immer unfassbar viel Spaß, weil es ist immer wieder ein Verrückter dabei, der eine Idee äußert, wo man sich denkt, das gibt es doch nicht. Da habe ich noch nicht dran gedacht, was ist so naheliegend. Und in dem Fall ist es so, dass ich zum zweiten Mal diesen Lehrgang einfach mit durchlaufen kann, was natürlich jetzt für mich persönlich ein Riesen-Mehrwert ist, total interessant ist, und dadurch auch irgendwie immer wieder ein Wissensvorsprung dazu kommt.
Wer sind denn dazu? Beispielsweise die Experten, die da die einzelnen Module dozieren?
Also wir haben aktuell hatten wir angefangen bei den wissenschaftlichen Grundlagen, den Philipp Obloch da, von Opta, der natürlich sehr viel Daten basiert macht, den Dr. Hendrik Weber, der Spielanalyse strategisch leitet bei der Deutschen Fußballliga. Wir hatten dann zum Beispiel aber auch jemanden wie Lars Kornetka da oder Hammin da, der als Co-Trainer Analyse von Bayer Leverkusen unglaublich viel Wissen mitbringt, genauso wie der Benjamin Weber von Borussia Dortmund, der eine ähnliche Rolle hat. Wir haben den DFB mit im Boot über Christopher Clemens, der Spielanalyse und Scouting für die A-Nationalmannschaft leitet, genauso wie jetzt Björn Müller oder Ralf Peter, die einfach auch im Modul Fußballlehre dann als Dozent arbeiten. Das sind Johannes Spohr, den ich noch vergessen habe, der die Scouting-Abteilung bei Red Bull Leipzig leitet. Mir ist hoffentlich niemand böse, der das jetzt zuhörst und nicht genannt wird. Aber es sind einfach tolle Leute.
Und weißt du, was ich super finde? Von diesen zehn Namen kannte ich zwei. Ich finde das total faszinierend. Es gibt einfach Bereiche des Fußballs und ich beschäftige mich jetzt nun wirklich schon ein paar Jahre intensiver mit den Bereichen. Nicht zuletzt für den Rasenfunk. Aber es gibt einfach Bereiche, die sind einem halbwegs tief eingedrungenen Line verschlossen. Und das ist nochmal so eine ganz eigene Ebene. Das finde ich super, total spannend. Die muss ich jetzt alle googeln, wenn ich da bin.
Mach das gerne, du findest sie auf unserer Internetseite. Aber das ist, glaube ich, das charakterisiert dieses Berufsbild auch wieder, um da nochmal irgendwie anzuschließen. Ich finde, es gibt so einen Leitspruch, den habe ich mir so ein bisschen auch auf die Fahne geschrieben, den ich ganz cool finde, der geht – work hard in silence, let success be your noise. Das ist, finde ich, ein cooler Leitspruch, der dieses Berufsbild einfach so ein Stück weit trifft, weil sie viel im Hintergrund arbeiten, weil sie nicht diejenigen sind, die jetzt die Chef-Trainer-Rolle haben oder ähnliches, die aber schon auch, wenn sie im Verein gut eingesetzt werden, eine tragende Rolle spielen können.
Jetzt hast du so lange deine Kompetenz bewiesen, dass ich diese Frage jetzt auch stellen kann. Gab es schon mal ein Spiel, wo du dich richtig veranalysiert hast, wo du Dinge rausgelesen hast von einem Gegner und dann haben die komplett anders gespielt und du hast dir gedacht, heine, nein, was habe ich denn da geliefert?
Ja klar.
Und dann in den Senkel gestellt worden vom Trainer?
Nee, ach, wenn man es gut analysiert, dann hat es der Analyst toll gemacht. Wenn man es schlecht analysiert und die Mannschaft schlecht spielt, dann ist die Mannschaft schuld. So, nein, klar, aber ich meine, wenn ich es vorhersagen könnte, dann wäre mein Marktwert deutlich höher.
Ja, vor allem müsstest du dann nicht mehr arbeiten, weil du Sportwettenkönig wärst.
Das kommt noch mit dazu und das ist Berufsrisiko. Da vertippt man sich natürlich regelmäßig. Ich sag mal, wenn man jetzt für die Medien arbeitet, ist es nochmal was anderes. Da schaut man ein bisschen neutraler auch drauf und dann kann man ungefähr abschätzen, was vielleicht da jetzt auch kommt. Wenn man jetzt im Verein arbeitet und man muss dem Trainer halt einfach eine Info geben und sagen, so und ich erwarte das so, bab, bab, bab, bab und dann tritt es nicht ein. Naja, weil die sich vielleicht auf uns auch vorbereitet haben oder wie auch immer.
Und abschließende Frage, kannst du ein Fußballschuh eigentlich noch so richtig genießen oder rattert es bei dir sofort los, wenn der Innenverteidiger den Ball rausspielt auf den Außenverteidiger, denkst du dir, ach, sehr interessant, muss ich mir merken und so weiter.
Ein Fußballspiel oder in Fußballschuhen?
Ein Fußballspiel.
Ja, ich kann es schon genießen irgendwie, weil…
Irgendwie.
Ja, also es ist was anderes. Ich glaube, jeder, der sich einfach damit intensiv auseinandersetzt, der achtet einfach zwangsläufig auf Dinge und schaut dann nochmal genauer hin. Ich glaube, da stecken wir irgendwie alle so ein bisschen in einem Boot, auch die sich einfach für die ganze Materie interessieren. Da würde ich jetzt nicht den Fußballfan, der vielleicht tatsächlich einfach beruflich gar nichts mit dem Fußball zu tun hat, in ein Boot setzen mit demjenigen, der einfach viel mit dem Fußball zu tun hat, wenn da das Interesse da ist. Das ist ja auch in Ordnung.
Also kannst du das nicht ausblenden. Bei mir geht es zum Beispiel so, ich gucke nur deswegen gerne Europa League, weil ich keine Europa League-Ausgaben im Rasenfunk mache, weil diese Spiele bis zu so einer gewissen K.o.-Rundenphase auch eine relativ geringe Bedeutung für die Bundesliga haben. Und da genieße ich das manchmal wahnsinnig. Bei der Champions League kann ich mich nicht zurücklehnen. Da muss ich gucken, wie Gladbach, Dortmund, Leverkusen, wie die Bayern spielen. Denn das sind einfach Erkenntnisse, die sammeln sich auch so automatisch. Aber bei der Europa League zum Beispiel kann ich das. Oder auch bei der 2. Bundesliga. Da nimmt das jetzt zwar immer mehr zu, weil so viele Hörer fragen, ob ich was zur 2. Liga mache. Da habe ich so langsam den Eindruck, ich muss da langsam mal drauf achten. Aber ich kann mich dann tatsächlich zurückzulehnen. Dann mache ich auch Twitter nebenher auf. Und dann denke ich mir, ach schön, jetzt lasse ich mich einfach mal überraschen, ob das ein gutes oder ein schlechtes Spiel wird. Also ich kann es noch manchmal ausschalten.
Ja, doch, so geht es mir schon auch. Zumal ja auch, man verändert ja auch den Blick, wenn man anfängt, die Dinge zu analysieren. Man muss ja auch auf Dinge achten und man kann nicht zwischendrin mal wegschauen und noch einen Schluck trinken oder was weiß ich. Man muss ja irgendwie so ein bisschen dranbleiben. Und deswegen kann ich das schon auf eine gewisse Weise. Und trotzdem hat sich aber einfach insgesamt mein Blick auf den Fußball verändert. Und das hat aber einfach damit zu tun, dass ich die Ehre hatte, mich jetzt einfach die letzten Jahre sehr intensiv damit beschäftigen zu dürfen. Und deswegen ist es vielleicht einfach manchmal ein anderer Blick drauf.
Ja, ja und vielleicht hilft es mir dann tatsächlich auch, dass ich nur die Fernsehbilder habe. Das macht es natürlich bei den Spielen, die ich dann tiefer analysieren will, macht es schwieriger, weil ich mir ganz viel Informationen ziehen muss. Also deswegen bin ich wahrscheinlich auch noch abhängiger von Daten, auch allein von Positionsdaten von Außenverteidigern, weil ich die halt einfach ganz oft nicht sehe. Wenn die Beinen vorne den Ball haben, dann zeigen die nicht, wie hoch die gerade stehen. Vielleicht ist das noch tatsächlich das, was da ein bisschen hilft, ein bisschen distanzierter, sich das Ganze anzugucken. Alex, ich danke dir sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat mir großen Spaß gemacht. Ich hätte dir gerne noch irgendeine Anekdote rausgeleiert. Ich weiß nicht, ob du mir noch irgendetwas erzählen kannst, was dir für immer in Erinnerung bleiben wird, wenn du auf deine Jahre als Spielanalyst zurückblickst. Du kannst dir Namen verfälschen.
Nein, ich habe ja vorher schon eine kleine Anekdote mit den gelaufenen Kilometern erzählt, die Richtung Fan-Kurve. Das war für mich so ein Meilenstein, wo ich gesagt habe, sei vorsichtig, wie du diese Daten interpretierst, weil sie können dich ganz schön in die Irre führen. Von daher war das so meine Anekdote des Tages. Mir fällt jetzt auch tatsächlich nichts mehr ein. Wenn mir noch etwas einfällt, musst du noch mal kurz vorbeikommen. Das gebe ich dir in einer Minute. Dann erzähle ich dir die kurze Anekdote. Aber ich darf mich auch sehr herzlich bedanken, dass du hier warst, dass du mich ausgewählt hast. Und ich hoffe natürlich auch, dass es dir insgesamt Spaß gemacht hat. Mir hat es sehr viel Spaß gemacht, auch auf der Ebene über Fußball zu diskutieren. Total cool.
Das finde ich sehr, sehr schön, auch nach dieser langen Zeit. Vielen Dank. Ich hoffe euch, liebe Hörer, hat es auch sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Hinterlasst uns gerne Feedback unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de oder in den sozialen Netzwerken Twitter und Facebook. Ich werde natürlich auch das Zertifikat von Alex verlinken. Ihr findet auch den Link zum Institut für Fußballmanagement. Wenn euch das noch weiter interessiert, könnt ihr euch da schlau machen. Und in diesem Sinne danke ich euch für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke, dass ihr dieses Tribünengespräch gehört habt. Und wenn es euch gefallen hat, hört vielleicht auch mal in unser Format die Schlusskonferenz und in den Kurzpass. Es gibt drei Sendungen des Rasenfunk. Es lohnt sich da mal ein bisschen zu suchen. Alle Infos auf rasenfunk.de. Danke fürs Zuhören, macht's gut, ciao!
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.